what are you doing I'm reading quietly
so I don't have to lie about it later
fandom the tweezers Moz needles under
magnifying glass absolutely not
let me at least try no you're being a
baby nothing you can say will change my
mind what if it gets infected and turns
green and they have to cut it off
I think it's numb great your handout
wait how do you plan on sterilizing the
needle mom uses all that match we're not
allowed to play with mattress what else
would work
alcohol stick your finger in there what
is it you know okay I hope I don't get
drunk
Alan tears Darrell I don't know but I'm
getting lightheaded no matter what
happened hold still
[Music]
I can't do it yes you can no I can't
just let me get it what did you slip and
stab me in the eye I'm not gonna slip
khloe's wins and we play beer back in
1989 the Milton Bradley company had
dozens of board games on the market but
only one where you were the doctor
operation came complete with a red light
up nodes 13 plastic body parts for
players to remove and most importantly
one pair of genuine tweezers my sister
performed a medical procedure using a
children's board game while I bravely
set very still
[Music]
I guess you could say there were two
heroes that day
gee what do you suppose that happened
hello in here
what's the kitchen smell like whiskey
ask huh oh dear Lord
wait so here what I did some me mine
[Music]